so we have this smart TV in the living
room oh people this is a smart TV oh is
it
smart oh is this [__] TV it's so
goddamn smart that one time I was in
there I had all the lights out cu we're
going to watch a movie you know but the
TV's so smart as I'm pressing on which
you don't even do don't hit the on
button you hit the on button that [__]
it up you got to press two other buttons
oh is that what I got to do is that what
I have to [__]
do don't scream like that you're right
buddy you're right
buddy this [__] thing if the lights
are out will not turn on cuz it's
thinking well the lights are out
obviously nobody is in the
room well maybe somebody's asleep on the
couch and they rolled over onto the
remote and meanwhile I am standing in
the dark you're going to turn on cuz I
[__] bought you and I [__] said so
right